bonatto diz pessoal daqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos já é mais
um vídeo e o estrago de que faz night at
freddy's 3 e hoje nós estamos aqui para
jogar então a segunda noite e eu espero
que o zé palavras não andem sempre atrás
de mim desta vez porque não vai ser um
problema porque se eu ficar sempre olhar
pra ele é os outros animais ônix vão
acabar por me apanhar e vai ser muito
difícil passar esta noite por isso eu
espero mesmo que os e palhaço agora
esteja quieto mas vamos lá então pessoal
segunda noite e eu estou preparado pra
porrada cueca vamos lá porque é que há
de novo agora você palhaço na irlanda
era aqui né
ok e pronto zé pedro já está com a
cabeça de fora mesmo já estando agora
começou
não há coisas novas não há coisas novas
por agora eu já sei que o palhaço pela
aciu do acaso nem cantar e tem que ficar
a olhar pra eu meu outro veja sério vou
ter que ficar olha pra ela eu tenho de
descobrir a forma de conseguir evitar
que além de dentro do meu quarto eu ou o
google ou faixa a faixa a faixa só
quando espero que comece porque alguém
vai chegar perto de mim por isso aí sim
aí foi que importa é que eu acho que
mesmo com as portas fechadas josé palace
vai entrar aqui dentro eu não choro não
passa o barulho não para bom perna vento
e trovoada
ela estava sempre será pouco meu até
funk o jogo todo lugar o jogo ou catar
que josé pinto
o palhaço é palhaço perturba as portas
a resposta sai pelas vai embora vai
embora vai embora
não entrar aqui meu como é que eu
consiga evitar o palhaço sem ficar a
olhar pra ele eu não sei pessoal não
sair este o botafogo difícil
será que eu tenho que olhar mesmo pelas
todas as noites meu vocês também alguma
maneira de manter o palhaço quieto eo
longe de mim nos comentários só porque
não estou mesmo a ver nenhuma forma anti
conseguir evitar espaço eu mesmo com as
portas fechadas
eu entro dentro do meu quarto melhor
como é que é possível pronto já sair
outra vez
o fred já deve ter sido aqui também
porque estava a pintar e e o palhaço na
irlanda
pior do que não atrapalhasse aqui né não
anda cantá lo
o gado só que foi o quarto funciona eu
acho que outra vez vou ter que ficar ali
abreu
será que eu tenho que ficar a olhar pelo
triunfo por ser e eu assim volta pra
caixa
será que é isso não esperem lá então
esperem lá eu vou então chora as portas
para que os outros animais tronics não
vai joão ou não me acompanhe e assim já
posso ficar a olhar para isto é manel
desapareceu é isso esperem espera a
caixa caixa está aberta a calma
mas só quem gosta e eu acho que consegui
arranjar a estratégia perfeita para o
palácio carros dependendo ataque
eu não volto pra caixa você ficar aqui à
espera e vou ter que ficar aqui à espera
e evento está tudo no lugar do meu ela
às vezes mexe provado até funk
aí eu vou ter que manter a marca também
é isso
será que é isso ok música para o seu
inteira mas com a música para será que é
isso que fugindo zeus é palhaço
outra foto virou pessoal é o guru do
palhaço vai aparecer outra vez eu tenho
as portas fechadas meu não não tinha as
portas fechadas como ela aparece nem
sequer uma por seu os de palhaços elite
em frente às câmeras meu como é que
possível toque pessoal você parece que o
gol sair da caixa e eu vou fazer o
seguinte às vezes vou ficar a olhar
algum tempo errou e depois foi joseane
matronic volta o olhar mais tempo para
eu falar se vou fazendo os informa que o
nome consigam atacar
eu acho que isto pode resultado ou não
não é mas vamos tentar não vai estar
sempre a cair em cima de mim não pode
ser melhor mas no entanto eu tenho que
controlar também o juiz denny matronic
ou seja é difícil vai ser difícil
ok eu acho que vou ficar só um pouco
mais tempo até à uma da manhã
depois vou ver os outros animais ônix e
volto para pagar só que eu já as vi da
caixa mil
isso vai ser muito difícil ok 90% do
treino 89 vai aprontar times como
contrariar o jogo aí uma da manhã eu vou
controlar então já anima tronics satuba
empolgue de palhaços bons e palhaços foi
pra que agora a 2
já no youtube nada caiu foi pra que
então então vou ficar a olhar para leis
mesmo vamos parar aqui pelo menos até às
duas da manhã os assuntos da manhã
ok e agora vamos sair pra quem ver se os
conteúdos lá o que é assunto de lá e
você pegasse o dólar agora
o vovô vôo você pegasse eu vou topar a
caixa não volto pra caixa andar aqui não
se fala mansa o laço
o que está aqui tá aqui josé coelho já é
conhecido saiu para estar aqui e quero
ficar na praia então é isso mesmo e
agora vou ficar a olhar para ela até às
três da manhã
se bem que eu tenho seqüência agora eu
tenho vai manter se pelo esquerdo tem
que fechar a porta meu e vou ter que
fechar a porta pessoal é quando aparece
a cair
olha eu sei daqui já a calma meta mas
isso agora é música parou e quando eu
voltar a ouvir o palhaço eu vou eu vim
aqui através de metrô mais rápido só
estou à espera que começa a música
duplas preocupar a máscara e agora que
não começa meu agora que eu espero que
não comece a música calma calma
o papa voltou eu acho que eu voltei para
dentro já para lá a não é agora não
fecha fecha fecha isso
eu caí e não posso ficar em foco se que
nenhum daniel aparecem sempre
mesmo com mais calma por ser meu
como é que eu faço isto como é que o
paciente fosse um jogo meu eu vou ter
que ficar a olhar outra vez com o
palhaço
vamos ver as outras salas calma e vai
presta né não
caos agora foi para a sala para esta
casa é sempre essa então eu vai-vai de
câmera 2 para a câmera 8 e depois vêm
para 4 ou então vai de 8 para outra
câmera qualquer mas como falho o vanoc
para quatro a descer alguma coisa assim
possível vou pescar flash lite não
porque já não o tenham já não tenho já
gastei o que é pessoal nem ficar olha
pra eu são três da manhã faltam três
foquem horas e eu vou ter que ficar ali
apareceu três horas
eu ainda vou passar junto olha só pra eu
tipo eu vou ficar até se buscar o
caraças buscar o caraças a meta mais
ok eu não conseguia primeiros minutos
mas é mais que na arte
assim conseguiu abrir o que vai
acontecer só não sei o que está
acontecendo eu não consigo a proteus em
flash lite é isso não viram o que flash
lite também influenciam as luzes do
quarto a sério
o pai está aqui né vou ficar olha pra eu
tá ok então fui lá e também influenciam
as luzes do quarto onde supostamente o
flash lite tipo que tem na mão um tipo
não é o que está no quarto
ok que também é falar passa para às 6h
por falhar eu não vai sair daqui sem que
o vai e por isso tato tranqüilo e espero
cruzei com ele não venha cá baixo né
ok cujo forças da manhã mil por favor
lá consegui passar filho da mãe
ok ok conseguir sol apesar de ficar
sempre olha a propagar-se o curso que
passar esta segunda noite e vamos para a
terceira o que agrada por ser um
minigame qualquer nem acho eu respirar
através de uma porta que ele o
verdadeiro clube todo o fred não vamos
olhar pra eu tá lá daqui né não vai mais
gostar né
espero eu não voltar porque já estou à
espera disto é prevísivel é previsível
já estou à espera do sul em natal livros
cara
então é isso pessoal nós não ficar por
aqui com mais um fait fred 3
atenção este não é o jogo oficial cá
está um fã game apenas um jogo feito por
um fã e fez um bem pessoal temos também
a noite três por isso se quiserem ver
mais noite daqui pra frente deixem o voz
forte apoio fiquem bem e até a próxima
ae